et glock du jour appelle la question
orale de monsieur jean pierre viala
monsieur ministre de l'écologie du
développement durable et d'énergies oui
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre et je m'associe aux propos qui
ont été données à votre endroit par mon
collègue jean claude lenoir la
progression du chômage illustre la
situation économique d'autres pays et
dont les politiques gouvernementales
n'ont pas à ce jour enrayer les effets
d'une conjoncture qui a certes une
dimension internationale mais à laquelle
viennent malheureusement s'ajouter les
rigidités complexité administrative que
le rapport qui vient d'être remis au
gouvernement au sujet des normes évalue
l'impact de celle-ci à presque 3
milliards d'euros soit par an soit 3,7
pour cent du pib national de cette
rigidité et voir une adaptation des
politiques l'exemple de la filière
solaire en est l'illustration marquée
déjà par le moratoire de 2010
à l'occasion de la conférence
environnement pas le gouvernement
s'était engagé à sauver cette filière en
grand danger
le 26 mars dernier le gouvernement a
annoncé le lancement d'un nouveau cycle
d'appel d'offres simplifié cette annonce
est accompagnée de la suppression des
deux premières périodes trimestriels
générant ainsi un trou d'air de
plusieurs mois les mesures annoncées en
janvier concernant le tarif d'achat et
l'appel d'offres complet ne sont pas de
nature à rassurer les professionnels
dont les propositions n'ont pas été
entendus l'ensemble de ces décisions
générera de façon certaine de graves
conséquences sur les emplois ne
permettra pas la mise en oeuvre des
investissements industriels attendus la
chute du nombre d installations
raccordées au réseau en trimestre 2012
et significative de l'état et d'extrême
fragilité de la filière photovoltaïque
pour l'appel d'offres creux deux prévues
en septembre et l'appel d'offres
simplifié en octobre n'ont retenu aucune
des observations et préconisations de la
profession ce qui augure mal de son
résultat et de ses effets sur l'économie
d'un filière il serait intéressant de
savoir comment le gouvernement entend
poursuivre le débat sur la transition
énergétique et prendre en compte les
conclusions du débat organisé le 17 mai
dernier à lyon et associer davantage la
filière à son avenir en ouvrant de
nouveaux sujets comme l'autoconsommation
limoges accueille la parole était
monsieur philippe martin ministre de
l'écologie dû développement durable
d'énergie
bien monsieur le sénateur mai si pour
votre question je les dis à l'instant et
je le confirme la transition énergétique
est une priorité absolue du gouvernement
pour l'année 2013 et dans ce cadre la
relance de la filière solaire est une
priorité acté lors de la conférence
environnementale qui s'était tenue en
septembre 2012 je rappelle devrait pas
être désagréable que dans une période
récente au cours des deux années qui ont
précédé sont pratiquement dix mille
emplois qui ont été détruits dans dans
cette filière est dans l'attenté des
conclusions du débat national sur la
transition énergétique le dossier final
ne sera transmis le 18 juillet prochain
le gouvernement a donc pris plusieurs
mesures d'urgence d'abord la
régularisation de la situation de 80
mille producteurs photovoltaïques
impacté par la décision du conseil
d'état du 12 avril 2012 qui avait eu
pour conséquence de suspendre leurs
contrats d'achat ensuite le gouvernement
a pris un ensemble de mesures d'urgence
le 7 janvier 2013 entrée en vigueur le
1er février la même année
ces mesures concernent toutes les
installations et vise à atteindre le
développement annuel d'au moins 1000
mégawatts par an de projets solaires en
france en 2013 soit le double des
objectifs annuels précédemment fixé
l'objectif est la relance de la filière
en réorientant la politique de soutien
vers la mise en place d'une filière
industrielle durable créatrice de valeur
ajoutée sur le territoire national
permettant de réduire le déficit
commercial du secteur solaire pour vous
répondre précisément sur le sénateur un
système d'appel d'offres simplifié avait
en effet été mis en place par le
précédent gouvernement pour les
installations de taille intermédiaire
sur toiture c'est à dire pour une
puissance installée entre 100 et 250
kilowatts les premiers résultats de cet
appel d'offres ont été peu satisfaisant
en termes de coûts et de retombées
industrielles
le gouvernement a donc décidé de
modifier le cahier des charges pour
notamment rajouter un critère
d'évaluation carbone qui permettra de
prendre en compte la contribution des
projets et la protection du climat c'est
car un panneau fabriqué en europe c'est
jusqu'à 5 fois moins d'émissions de co2
qu'un panneau importés d'asie cet appel
d'offres prévoit un volume global de 120
mégawatts répartis en trois périodes de
candidature entre le 1er juillet 2013 et
le 30 juin 2014 monsieur le sénateur n'y
a donc aucun trou d'air dans cet appel
veuf qui générera des investissements
cumulés de l'ordre de 250 millions
d'euros la date limite de remise des
offres était fixée au 31 octobre 2013 la
désignation des lorrains pourrait
ensuite avoir lieu en 2014 pour une mise
en service des projets lauréats en 2015
au delà des mesures d'urgence le débat
national sur la transition énergétique
dont les recommandations ne seront remis
je voulais dit le 18 juillet prochain
déboucheront sur un projet de loi de
programmation qui sera déposé au
parlement probablement
examiné dès le début de 2014 cette fois
comportera des mesures pérennes pour
soutenir efficacement la montée en
puissance des énergies renouvelables
dans la perspective de l'objectif fixé
par le président de la république à
l'horizon 2025 merci monsieur le
ministre monsieur vial
munch ministre je vous remercie de vos
engagements et de ces précisions
d'ailleurs je n'avais pas manqué de lire
avec la plus grande attention vos
déclarations d'hier
évoquant l'importance de la transition
énergétique et l'enjeu structurants en
bâtir développement économique d'emploi
de solidarité je le dis parce
qu'effectivement mais vous me donnerez
acte que j'ai évoquées moi même les
vicissitudes qui ont été rencontrés dans
le passé notamment
le moratoire de 2010 avec ses effets
mais j'insiste sur ce point monsieur
ministre parce que à l'époque c'était
justement concernant le marché des
particuliers dont tout le monde
considérait qu'il ne devrait pas être
affectée alors que c'est celui qui est
le plus créateur d'emplois qui a été le
plus sinistré et donc quand je vous dis
que aujourd'hui je crains que les
mesures avancées par les professionnels
ne soit pas suffisamment pris en compte
par creux 2 et
l'appel d'offres simplifié d'octobre je
vous demande monsieur le ministre avec
vos services de regarder avec attention
ce qui va se passer car je ne voudrais
pas qu'on réédite ce qui s'est passé
déjà dans le passé parce que nous
n'avons pas tenu compte des
préconisations des professionnels je
remercie monsieur le ministre